pour terminer cette édition spéciale du
78 nous sommes allés à la rencontre d'un
plus petit constructeur l'uméo bonsoir
Daniel moulen vous en êtes le président
cette cette entreprise est basée dans
les evelines justement on peut peut-être
préciser vos activités justementumo
c'est un petit constructeur c'est pas
réducteur de dire ça non c'est un petit
constructeur qui cherche à fabriquer des
voitures en peties séries dans des des
niches où ne sont pas les grands
constructeurs donc on a choisi de faire
des véhicules électriques au départ
puisque efftivement les grands
constructeurs peineent à démarrer sur le
véhicule électrique ce qui est tout à
fait logique vous êtes mis dans une
niche un petit peu tout à fait une niche
nos véhicules sont exclusifs c'estàdire
que pour le moment il n'y a aucun
concurrent des trois véhicules que nous
présentons juste avant de présenter les
différents véhicules que vous présenter
on peut remarquer que vous êtes bien
situé sur le salon de l'automobile au
milieu de gros constructeurs jaguar Land
Rover par exemple c'est un choix aussi
pour une meilleure visibilité sur le
salon de c'est pas tout à fait un choix
nous étions là il y a 2 ans nous étions
là il y a 4 ans on reste un petit peu
chez nous c'est les autres qui sont
venus à nous mais c'est pas un problème
alors quels sont les trois différents
véhicules que vous présentez on va
commencer forcément par celui dans
lequel on se trouve ce cabriolet alors
c'est un cabriolet nous on dit que c'est
un roster c'estàd que c'est une version
découvrable de la voiture que nous que
nous lançons en production en ce moment
qui est Neoma donc c'est un Neoma roster
on a perdu deux places dans le dans le
design mais par contre c'est très
séduisant c'est très dynamique c'est fun
enfin c'est on aime bien cette image
moderne mais c'est quand même un
véhicule électrique véhicule 100 %
électrique il quelle autonomie par
exemple alors normalement s'il utilise
les mêmes ingrédients que ce que nous
avons sur Neoma standard on aura 140 km
d'autonomie euh avec une vitesse de
pointe actuellement qui est limitée à
110 mais celle-là peut-être qu'on
augmentera un peu bon enfin c'est les
les les objectifs c'est de faire un
véhicule vraiment fun qui plaise qui
soit moins utilitaire on va dire que que
Neoma qui qui est une très belle voiture
mais qui est un petit peu moins fun ça
se recharge facilement c'est toujours la
question qu'on pose avec l'électrique
mais est-ce que ça se recharge
facilement alors ça c'est une une
caractéristique de nos véhicules nous
avons choisi de faire des petits
véhicules donc avec des petites
capacités ce qui permet de se recharger
sur une PR standard de 230 V 16 ampères
si vous avez une ligne de 220 V chez
vous qui est de bonne qualité vous
pouvez recharger c'est ce que je fais
moi à la maison sans aucun problème j'ai
même pas eu besoin de vérifier c'est une
installation qui est Neve mais il faut
il faut vérifier l'installation mais 16
ampères c'est pas ça passe bien et c'est
très pratique c'est une prise normal
donc il y a vraiment beaucoup de
possibilités de se charger et avec cet
argument là justement est-ce que les
ventes suivent derrière bah
automatiquement on a simplicité pour
pour la recharge donc les gens qui ont
quand même la possibilité de se charger
chez eux
effectivement sont intéressés par ce
type de voiture pourquoi se tourner
plutôt vers luminéo plutôt que que
Renault par exemple Renault qui a des
véhicules électriques également quels
sont les diff différ par rapport à ce
soit la T la Zoe par exemple alors si on
prend tezy donc la la plus proche c'est
c'est
l'asmeraas SMA est une vraie voiture
elle se conduit avec un permis normal
elle peut aller sur autoroute elle est
fermée elle a du chauffage donc ce sont
des vraiment des caractéristiques très
différentes par contre dans le cas de de
Neoma c'est une voiture qui fait
2,70 donc qui est très courte elle fait
1,20 de moins qu'une qu'une Zoé et là
c'est plus le fait de pouvoir se garer
très facilement c'està dire qu'on est
tout seul dans sa voiture 80 % du temps
et on prend quand même une grosse
voiture et nous on dit c'est pas très
logique il vaudrait mieux avoir une
voiture plus petite et quand même avoir
la possibilité d'emmener quelqu'un parce
que ça arrive et c'est très gênant de
pas pouvoir emmener quelqu'un donc vous
présentez trois véhicules vous en avez
mentionné deux jusici à présent il en
manque un oui le trè c'est c'est le
roadster le roadster c'est plus pour se
faire plaisir c'est un chocar c'est pas
un véhicule qu'on vend en ce moment mais
vu les résultats normalement en d'ici un
an et demi je pense qu'il sera il sera
en production le MIN existe depuis
combien de temps ça fait 6 ans qu'on a
créé la société et on a présenté la
première voiture en 2008 au salon de
Genève donc Neoma concept comme comme
aujourd'hui on présente le roadster
concept et puis après on l' fait évoluer
jusqu'à avoir une voiture aboutie avec
une belle marge de prod progression
pardon pour pour l'entreprise vous voyez
où par exemple dans 6 ans dans 6 ans
supplémentaires dans dans 6 ans on
espère vendre plusieurs milliers de
véhicules par
an normalement électrique très bien
merci beaucoup Daniel donc le président
de cette entreprise l'uméo ce petit
constructeur basé dans les ivelines
c'est quasiment la fin de cette édition
spéciale du 78 consacré au Salon de
l'automobile qu'en avez-vous retenu
qu'en avez-vous pensé vos réponses dans
les allées du salon vraiment formidable
je pensais que l'ambiance était superbe
cet après-midi les voitures sont très
très très beaux les mannequins aussi al
c'est vraiment un beau salon bon je
trouve qu'il manque un peu de nouveauté
mais c'est un très très très beau salon
de belles voitures pas mal d'innovation
beaucoup de véhicules électriques
notamment qui ont l'air très
intéressants donc beaucoup d'innovation
par rapport à ça c'est ça qui est
vraiment le plus agréable alors je viens
depuis que je suis gamin et maintenant
j'habite aux États-Unis depuis 25 ans
donc ça fait quand même quelques années
[Musique]
et
le mieux c'est en anglais donc c'estàd
qu'il est vraiment formidable ça ça m'a
fait rêver